It's Our intention Our intention is
everything nothing happens on this
planet without it not one single thing
has ever been accomplished without
intention
I was two people my whole life I was in
the living room entertaining people
being a monkey
you know doing my thing for the company
and
and trying to relieve my mother who was
suffering
she had uh rheumatoid arthritis and
phlebitis and everything everything
under the sun that was nagging at her
and she was depressed
and I wanted her to be free
and I wanted her to realize
that her life was worth something
because she gave birth to someone who's
worth something
and then I would go into my room
and I would sit
with a legal pad I was a little kid I
would sit there and I would try to
figure out what it meant what it was all
about
why are we here
what is this
and one day I read something from Buddha
that said that all spirituality
is about relieving suffering
suddenly realized
that's what I'm doing in the other room
and
and I'm aligned you know this my purpose
is aligned with this
so I felt incredibly lucky I lose sight
of that all the time I get caught up in
different concerns and ego concerns
but I'm so lucky to be a part of this
community and to to
to do something that is of value
and I really cherish that and we are all
one thing it really is true I woke up
and
I suddenly got it
I understood how thought
was just
an illusory thing
and how
thought
is responsible for if not all most of
the suffering we experience
and then I suddenly felt like I was
looking at these thoughts from another
perspective and I wondered
who is it
that's aware that I'm thinking
and suddenly I was
thrown into this expansive amazing
feeling
of freedom
from myself
from my problems
I saw
that I was bigger
than what I do I was bigger than my body
I was everything and everyone
I was no longer a fragment
of the Universe I was the universe
and ever since that day I've been trying
to get back there
comes and goes
it's like riding a wave
sometimes I'm on sometimes I'm off but
at least I know where I want to go and
that I want to take as many people with
me as I possibly can because the feeling
is amazing you've made a decision to
transcend
and to leave Darkness behind
and it takes a champion to make that
decision I really want to speak to the
fact that I've had some challenges in
the last couple of years myself
ultimately I believe that suffering
leads to Salvation
and in fact it's the only way
that we have to somehow
accept and not deny the feel our
suffering
and feel our losses and then we make one
of two decisions we either decide to go
through the gate resentment
which leads to Vengeance which leads to
self-harm
which leads to harm to others or will go
through the gate of forgiveness which
leads to Grace
and uh your
being here
is an indication that you've made that
decision already
you've made the decision to walk through
the gate forgiveness to Grace we are so
trapped all of us especially who have
suffered terribly trauma uh to think of
that as a real thing and there is a
difference between real villagers and
imaginator and it's hard to turn that
off meditation or name and for a lot of
people has been a way to turn that off
you know and or recognize that those
thoughts are just thoughts like clouds
that cross the sky
uh they will pass on and uh and to
gently pull yourself back to a place so
peace and just to stop the spiral of
thought man we get up in the morning and
we open our eyes and the show begins you
know and it's a thriller for some people
and and you can't help but get caught up
in it it is important a couple of times
during the day to stop and go wait
this is just as real as those Stars I am
bigger than these thoughts I am bigger
than this body they talk about
omnipresence in church and nobody really
thinks about what that means what it
means is every cell of your body is God
everything is gone everything is divine
when you do good things when you decide
to transcend the negativity and attempt
to do something positive for you through
your family
you are the heart of God
you are the eyes of God when you speak
from that place you are God's voice and
when you make a loaf of bread in this
place in this kitchen
that is a Eucharist you're blessing
people with your work you're serving
the world with your work with your
effort that is a Eucharist that is the
body of Christ
and that peace
that peace that we're after
lies somewhere beyond personality beyond
the perception of others Beyond
invention and disguise even Beyond
effort itself you can join the game
fight the wars play with form all you
want
but to find real peace you have to let
the armor go your need for acceptance
can make you invisible in this world
don't let anything stand in the way of
the light that shines through this form
risk being seen in all of your glory
painting is one of the ways I free
myself from concern a way to stop the
world through total mental spiritual and
physical involvement but even with that
comes a feeling of divine
dissatisfaction
because ultimately we're not the avatars
we create
we're not the pictures on the film stock
we are the light that shines through
all else is just smoke and mirrors
distracting but not truly compelling
I've often said that I wish people could
realize all their dreams and wealth and
fame and
so that they could see that it's not
where you're going to find your sense of
completion
like many of you
I was concerned about going out into the
world and doing something bigger than
myself
until someone's smarter than myself made
me realize that there is nothing bigger
than myself this is the voice of the ego
and if you listen to it there will
always be someone who's doing better
than you no matter what you gain ego
will not let you rest
it will tell you that you cannot stop
until you've left an indelible mark on
the earth until you've achieved
immortality
how tricky is this ego
that it would tempt us with the promise
of something we already possess
and don't worry if you miss your cue
because there's always doors opening
they keep opening and when I say life
doesn't happen to you it happens for you
I really don't know if that's true
I'm just making a conscious choice to
perceive challenges as something
beneficial so that I can deal with them
in the most productive way
you'll come up with your own style
that's part of the fun
oh and uh why not take a chance on faith
as well
take a chance on faith not religion but
faith not hope but faith
I don't believe in hope hope is a beggar
hope walks through the fire and Faith
leaps over it do you feel like you're
separated from the rest of the world and
what's going on no not separated at all
in fact it's the exact opposite you know
I uh don't get me wrong you know Jim
Carrey is a great character and I was
lucky to get the part but I don't think
of that as me anymore you don't ever not
at all not really no uh I used to be a
guy who was experiencing the world and
now I feel like the world and the
universe experiencing a guy